ich bin beeindruckt wie die annegret
kramp karrenbauer was hören schwieriger
namen in der politik hkk ist also
einfacher zu sagen wie sie zu ihrer
verantwortung steht jetzt in diesem
afghanistan-konflikt und sie ist die
einzige in der regierungsmannschaft die
sich hinstellt und sagt ich halte meinen
kopf hin ich habe die befehls- und
gewalt
kommandogewalt und ich stehe vorne an
der brücke und muss deswegen auch die
verantwortung übernehmen und ich werde
sehr genau überlegen was für schlüsse
ich also wenn das alles vorbei ist ich
daraus ziehen und und sieht man sie
erklärt quasi dass sie bereit ist
zurückzutreten und ich finde das ist so
ein wichtiges demokratisches prinzip
dass man verantwortung nicht nur
anmeldeten sagt er ich habe die ich hab
die verbal sondern dass man dann auch
sagt okay und ich trage auch die
konsequenzen und das hat bisher noch
keiner in der regierungsmannschaft so
deutlich gesagt heiko maas hat
kategorisch einen rücktritt abgelehnt
aber nach dieser moralischen
steilvorlage von aa kk mit der sich so
sind die so gut verstanden hat
kommt jetzt ein bisschen schwammig nach
ja da muss man mal sehen also vielleicht
ja da muss man dann wirklich
verantwortung übernehmen aber die
verantwortung die haben wir alle also er
selber übernimmt nicht die alleinige
verantwortung für seinen bereich sonne
das ist die ganze regierungsmannschaft
ja und überhaupt auch alle anderen
beteiligten staaten und ich finde das
ist ziemlich schwammig und ich und
irgendwo
ich hoffe dass ich jetzt nicht
männerfeindlich dinge ein bisschen
typisch für für für männer weil dem feld
ist sehr schwer
macht abzugeben und einfluss und ich
glaube dass frauen also auch nicht
gerade in der politik er bereits sind
konsequenzen zu tragen und zu sagen okay
bei
den frauen ist die macht nicht so
wichtig sondern das was sie bewirken
können und wenn sie etwas nicht bewirken
können wenn sie wenn sie falsch liegen
dann treten sie eben zurück also ich
weiß dass ich damit viele männer vor den
kopf es gibt auch ausnahmen ist genauso
machtgierige frauen wie es machthungrige
männer gibt aber in normalen fall sind
frauen eher bereit zurückzutreten mir
macht jetzt den mann los das ist
natürlich ein ich meine diese
wunderbare großartige einführung dieses
sie glühende
solidaritätsbekundung gegenüber frau
karin beier kramp karrenbauer zeigt
einfach dass die frauensolidarität
wirklich unverbrüchlich ist ja muss
vorausschicken die deutsche bundeswehr
macht in afghanistan den viel besseren
job aus diese miserabel geführten
amerikaner weil das was die bundeswehr
jetzt gemacht und da ist ja vollkommen
hornbach vor ort mit diesem
sonderkommando mit diese
befreiungsaktion was er sogar franzosen
zu einer art verbalen blumenstrauß in
der bild -zeitung motiviert hat das
finde ich großartig aber ich muss jetzt
doch ein paar skeptisch ist auch auf den
einstreuen ich weine nur weil ein
politiker oder eine politikerin sagt ich
halte dann mal meinen kopf hin ja das
ist noch gar nichts das ist einfach mal
ein spruch zurückgetreten ist sie noch
nicht was ihr wollt auch schon länder
zurückgetreten friedrich merz zum
beispiel ist zurückgetreten und auch vom
rücktritt zurückgetreten auch am ende
tritt
zurück
aber ich möchte einmal diese wandel
festhalten also frauen können
zurücktreten männer ist ein sehr gut
darin vom rücktritt zurück zu treten das
muss man einmal festhalten das
haben wir von schweinen ist kann
eigentlich nur vom schweizer dass das
auch schon wieder ran
das ist journalismus aber dass
also das war gut hier tragen aber ich
weiß ja dass ich oder wir wissen ja alle
dass ist längerem offene diskussion über
eine mal besonderen schlüssel
ministerium der minister oder die
ministerin mit neben der politischen
erfahrung auch eine spezielle erfahrung
auf dem gebiet und das gilt mit
sicherheit für das
verteidigungsministerium jetzt sage ich
mir und das ist kein angriff gegen hkk
verrückt und muss ich also hoch sagen
weil ich die schätze ich bin im saarland
hatte der beliebtheitswerte 70 und 80
prozent die hat da beide wahlkämpfe
gehen heiko maas schon als
ministerpräsident von der kammer angela
merkel sagt rudi ist so beliebt mehr
holen sie nach berlin da wurde sie
generalsekretärin da wurde so
bundesvorsitzender immer ging rosa laie
nach brüssel und dann hat es danach
gehst du mal dahin so jetzt war ich da
auch ich hatten cola zum kauf neuer
kaufmann nein ich habe
betriebswirtschaft für die zwar auch bei
der bundeswehr grundausbildung in
schwarzenborn das sagte mann der liebe
gott schuf in seinem zorn gemacht ich
musste da rennen ich hatte solche blasen
an den füßen abc alarm aufdrehen wir
gewehr granaten panzerfäuste all den
ganzen scheiß dann war ich nachher schön
als kleiner bub division starb in
schloss oranienstein fünfte band version
nato-verbände noch planen durfte ich nur
eins nämlich einer gefragt hast du die
qualität
um in einem inneren
verteidigungsministerium vorne irgendwo
mitzumischen dann hätte ich nein gesagt
und somit ist es doch klar das programm
bauer natürlich eine top
ministerpräsident damals mit riesen
werden ja und man sieht ja auch viel und
jetzt das gebe ich allerdings dir gerne
auch zu dass sie jetzt auch stets dazu
sagt nähe könnten bis zum rumpf und dort
hätte bundesnachrichtendienst und dort
hat der mich als spieler informiert und
hat mich mein team meine generalstab 90
stellen zuständig ab es geht nur darum
die diskussion hat mein herz weiterhin
alleine das befähigt sie im nächsten
kabinett nicht als verteidigungsminister
rinner bereit wieder einmal richtig
gemacht wo sie schon mal rein du darfst
nicht alles wiederfinden was du gesagt
hast nämlich der wesentliche seine
ausführungen es spielt doch keine rolle
ob man als verteidigungsminister einen
flammenwerfer von einem toten
ich würde ich sagen es kaum und das
können sie horst wir wollen wir nicht
eine bescheidenheit die die fordern den
tag gelegt auf seine bescheidenheit mit
der du dich jetzt eben aus politiker
dienstwagen
haben
vor diese sendung noch als quasi hall of
fame ruhmeshalle von annegret kramp
karrenbauer
muss ich einmal damit sie jetzt muss ich
hier und muss ich einmal ganz ganz so
weit gewesen dass sie ziemlich lang
ziemlich viel mist gebaut hat als
verteidigungsministerin und dass sie
lange gebraucht hat bis sie sich vom amt
der cdu parteivorsitzende hat vertreiben
lassen und dass sie auch als
generalsekretär in einer zeit gearbeitet
hat und der die cdu massenhaft
mitglieder verloren hat ich wollte es
nur einmal sagen weil die sechs minuten
davor gelangen ja wie eine uhr mesz
erklärung
[Musik]